[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i am going
to explain an american comedy drama film
called an american pickle spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie begins in the year 1919 in a
place called schlupsk in eastern europe
herschel greenbaum is a struggling
jewish laborer who works as a ditch
digger his job is tiresome and earns him
little to no money most of the money he
earns he spends on buying new shovels
which break frequently herschel narrates
that his life is tough but that is only
until he meets the love of his life
sarah for the first time by buying her a
golden fish from the market he wins her
over and the two become friends they
have a lot in common like the fact that
both of their parents were murdered by
russian cossacks the pair's greatest
wish is to be able to afford their own
gravestone one day times were simpler
back then huh bonding over murder and
dreaming of death a few months later
they get married hoping for a peaceful
life together however their plans are
ruined when the russian cossacks attack
the village right after the wedding
ceremony
to escape their life of living in fear
the couple moves to america they are
frequently called anti-semitic slang but
herschel claims that the americans treat
them way better than the russians did he
gets a job at a pickle factory where he
earns a nickel for every 10 rats he
kills the couple works hard and finally
buys two graves so that they can be
together forever not long after that
sarah gets pregnant with their first
child but everything changes when one
day herschel falls into a vat of pickles
just as the factory is condemned for
health reasons the vat is covered and he
is stuck inside it for the next 100
years time passes but no one comes to
look for him until two youngsters enter
the factory and open the vat's lid that
was accidentally knocked out by their
drone even after a hundred years of
being stuck inside of it herschel is
alive and well perfectly preserved by
the brine his story becomes the talk of
the city and a convention is held to
explain how he was able to survive the
scientists provide a very believable
explanation which the media accepts
following that herschel is taken to the
hospital for a checkup and is found to
be in perfectly good condition except
for his anger issues on running a
background check the doctors find out
that all of herschel's descendants are
dead except for his great-grandson ben
after they contact him they find out
that he lives in brooklyn and is more
than happy to pick up his great
grandfather
ben meets herschel and is surprised to
see that the two look almost identical
that's right since james franco has been
cancelled seth rogen now has to star in
movies with himself when herschel steps
out of the building for the first time
he is mesmerized by the skyscrapers and
the vehicles everything has changed
since he last saw new york ben is
excited to be able to show his great
grandfather all of the new inventions
when they reach ben's apartment herschel
is even more shocked used to living in
poverty he thinks that the place is
massive and luxurious and honestly for
new york he's not wrong who did ben have
to kill to get this place
ben welcomes him to live there as long
as he wants but herschel thoughtfully
says he doesn't want to be a burden on
him herschel's excitement only gets
bigger when he gets to drink seltzer
water a drink that was reserved for
royalty in his time ben makes alexa play
an old song and the two dance together
after settling down herschel asks ben
what he does for work assuming that he
might be a doctor or a lawyer he is
visibly confused when ben says he is a
freelance app developer ben explains
that he has been developing an app
called boot bop for the past five years
and is very passionate about it it is a
service that checks companies ethics to
help the consumer choose whether to buy
their products herschel sees no pictures
of family on the walls so he asks ben
about this ben shows him a family photo
album which makes herschel emotional he
sees sarah's picture and finds out that
he had a son named mort on being asked
about his parents ben becomes
uncomfortable he says that they passed
away in an accident the following day
they go to visit the graves of their
family and to hershel's horror this
cemetery is in shambles seeing his
wife's poorly kept tombstone he can't
help but cry
some workers are putting up a billboard
of russian vodka right on top of their
graves this reminds herschel of the
cossacks who killed his parents and
loved ones back in shlubsk an enraged
herschel asks them to put it down but
they do not oblige so he assaults them
ben tries to stop him but gets beaten up
in the process this results in both of
them being arrested ben spends a large
sum of money and bails them out herschel
then convinces ben to finally message
his investor friend about his app he
responds immediately so ben goes to a
meeting with him but he is devastated to
find out that the investors aren't
interested in him because of his newly
minted criminal record he returns home
and blames herschel for making his life
go downhill herschel doesn't understand
ben's ideas and claims that they should
start a pickle business instead in a fit
of rage ben says that sarah would be
ashamed of him if she were alive at that
moment herschel vows to build a pickle
empire and make his dead relatives proud
by raising enough money to cut down the
billboard he storms out of the apartment
after calling ben a dishonor to their
family name at first he goes to the
grocery store to buy cucumbers but they
are too expensive while wandering around
he notices that the garbage bin outside
of the store has packed cucumbers in it
he brings them with him and in a similar
fashion collects all the necessary
ingredients from dumpsters around the
city using a shopping cart salt and
rainwater he is finally able to make the
brine for the pickles following that he
puts up a tiny pickle stand by the side
of the road he sells his first jar for
four dollars to a couple since he hasn't
added any preservatives and is selling
them at a lower price than the grocery
store the number of customers increases
he also asks them to bring the jars back
after they are finished this way the
people believe his business is
environmentally friendly
his customers start to post about him on
social media which grows his business
exponentially herschel's old-fashioned
charm is hipster gold soon ben also
finds out about herschel's local pickle
business that everyone is talking about
while he struggles to create ideas for
his new app he is told that herschel's
business is a massive hit this makes him
jealous one day he calls the health
department and files a complaint about
herschel using products found in trash
bins to create his pickles this causes
his business to shut down and he has
fined twelve thousand dollars herschel
is left right where he started without
any resources two of his faithful
customers advise him to hire interns
since he wouldn't have to pay them
herschel is inspired by the idea even
though he thinks it is similar to
slavery herschel is wrong about this at
least slaves were provided with food and
the place to sleep he hires a group of
interns to brine and package the pickles
soon they are using proper ethical
methods to make them and are approved by
the health department the interns also
help him sell the pickles on a larger
scale making the business quickly go
back up in no time herschel earns enough
money to purchase the billboard and take
it down in the meantime ben sees that
the people who were supposed to invest
in his app are now wanting to invest in
herschel's business to proclaim his
victory herschel brings the billboard
back to ben's apartment he says that he
wants to help ben because at the end of
the day they are family but ben is not
fond of the idea and just wants the man
to go away as they chat herschel
comments how the polish men are stupid
this gives ben another idea on how he
can end the pickle business he suggests
herschel create a twitter account that
evening with an intern's help herschel
tweets controversial statements about
women religion and homosexuality the
following day people swarm before his
shop and protest against his ideas
urging everyone to boycott his pickle
business his interns also leave his side
and to join the protesters even after
this herschel stays firm in his opinions
as time passes he earns support from
conservative groups who see him as an
icon of free speech and empowerment he
even gets selected to appear for a
debate with a college professor on the
subject of ethics at first his
statements about women in general are
seen as bold opinions but then a
disguised ben from the audience asks him
about his thoughts on christianity
herschel proceeds to say that the virgin
mary invented christianity to hide the
fact that she had sexual relations he
calls everyone who believes in jesus an
idiot because of the comment the people
who were on his side until now chase him
down the streets of new york wanting to
kill him for disrespecting their
religion he manages to survive by hiding
in an alleyway that night he sees a news
report about protests happening all
across america to boycott him once and
for all
authorities start to dig up his past
wanting to deport him back to eastern
europe moreover because of the outdated
filing system in the storage facility
the paperwork for herschel's arrival
cannot be located this gives the
authorities an excuse to revoke his
citizenship he is declared a fugitive
illegal alien and the people are asked
to report to the police if they see him
with no way out herschel goes to his
only family ben for help not wanting to
return to schlupsk he says that he will
move to canada and start a business
there ben reluctantly agrees to help him
for the final time the two drive to the
canadian border and walk through the
woods to illegally enter the country on
their way ben accidentally cuts his palm
and herschel tears a piece of his
clothes to bandage the wound at night he
hugs his great-grandson to keep him warm
although ben has said vicious things to
him herschel still considers him family
the following morning they finally reach
the border but have to hide when they
are almost spotted by border patrol
while chatting ben feels bad for
herschel and confesses that he was the
one who asked him the question about
christianity because he wanted to
sabotage the pickle business ben hopes
that herschel will forgive him but he is
punched in the face instead he falls
unconscious and the commotion attracts
the border patrol's attention herschel
hides and finds ben's razor and clothes
in a bag he quickly thinks of a way to
escape shaves his beard and disguises
himself as ben the officers arrest ben
thinking he is herschel while herschel
himself is let free because he has ben's
id following that ben is put on trial
but his case is considered a joke when
he pleads that he is not herschel
eventually he is sent to schlubsk
instead of his great-grandfather he is
alone and cold in a town filled with
strangers who do not speak english he
tries to talk to people asking them for
a place he can spend the night in he
ends up in a synagogue and decides to
stay there meanwhile herschel begins to
feel awful for his great-grandson he
goes to his apartment and looks through
the family photo album while reminiscing
about the old days he finds a drawing
that ben had made of his parents as a
kid it is only then that herschel finds
out boop and bob were pet names that ben
gave his parents he realizes that ben
had always wanted to honor his parents
and feels terrible that he misjudged him
following that the man decides to go to
schlupsk and bring ben back home
meanwhile in schlupsk ben is asked by
the people of the synagogue to perform
prayer and pay respect to the dead
family members he gets emotional during
the prayer but it makes him feel a lot
lighter afterward to his surprise
herschel appears in front of him and
apologizes for his actions he says that
ben is exactly what he wanted his
descendants to become and claims his
parents must be proud of him the pair
reconcile and go to a lake that used to
be sarah's favorite spot they discuss
starting a pickle business together
where they can pickle more than just
cucumbers ben offers to create a website
for their company through which they can
sell worldwide the two finally return to
brooklyn and pay a visit to sarah's
grave in the final scene they pray
together in the honor of their dead
family members subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching